Speaker 1: Well, the Republican Party is finally
behaving rationally. Republicans are panicking
that the now multiple arrests of failed former
president twice impeached, twice indicted,
Donald Trump may actually boomerang on them and
be damaging. Big picture. There's an interesting
article in the Hill by Alexander Bolton called
Republicans fear Trump Legal Woes will boomerang
on them. Senate Republicans are worried that
Trump's legal troubles will create a major
headwind for Republican candidates in 2024. They
say the battle between the Justice Department and
Trump, who pleaded not guilty Tuesday just as his
unsubstantiated claims that the 2020 election was
stolen, became a prominent point of debate in last
year's primaries. They worry Trump's dominance of
the media spotlight will turn off swing voters,
especially suburban women, and hurt their chances
of taking back the Senate or protecting their
small House majority. The article goes on to
include a number of quotes from different
Republicans. This is a logical reaction to
what is going on now. There is a group of people
that is choosing to narrowly focus only on the
presidential race, and we will look at the polling
in the presidential race a little bit later today.
You could convince yourself and maybe others,
if you look only at the presidential race,
that it is quite binary and it doesn't have any
trickle down effect. What is happening with Donald
Trump? Let me tell you what I mean by that. You
could look at the Trump arrests and look at the
Republican primary and say to yourself, listen, if
Trump's arrests hurt Trump, someone else will win
the primary and then that person will face Joe
Biden. And they might win or they might lose,
and it will have nothing to do with what is going
on with Trump. In other words, the context is
Trump's legal troubles will only affect who is the
Republican nominee. And beyond that, it will not
have any broader impact on the Republican Party.
There are two problems with that relatively narrow
focus. Problem number one is that indeed,
if Trump is leading the Republican primary
for several more months, but then he's arrested a
third time and potentially arrested a fourth time,
and then it becomes clear he can't really campaign
because he's just going from courthouse to
courthouse and Ron DeSantis or someone else ends
up winning the primary. The impact of that last
minute collapse by Donald Trump doesn't end with
the Republican primary. And there is the belief,
and I believe it is a warranted belief,
that if such a shakeup were to take place,
it would weaken whoever is the eventual Republican
nominee against Joe Biden. So that's one way in
which thinking of the Trump arrests only is
relevant to the Republican primary is wrong.
But what Republicans are increasingly concerned
about now is very serious, which is that this
entire circus atmosphere and sideshow nature
of what is going on, which also, by the way,
includes some Republican candidates saying I
would pardon Trump and others saying I wouldn't,
and this just becoming the circus that it is.
It may just be very bad for random Republican
senators seeking reelection. Four random members
of the House of Representatives, some who are
supporters of Trump and some who are not, that it
will create a broader problem for any Republican
that is running in November of 24, including
simply that the Trump fiasco might reduce turnout
and make some voters stay home who would otherwise
vote to reelect some of these Republicans. It's
too early to know whether that fear is backed by
data, but intuitively, it makes a ton of sense.
We'll leave that question there. And now I want
to look a little bit at some new national polling.